you
hi everyone is Jerry this is video 9
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and we're going to have a look
at several chess tactics I'll be
providing the definitions of several
chess tactics and showing what that
looks like on board
the tactics in particular the terms in
particular that we'll be covering here
are as follows Fork pin skewer
deflection discovered attack double
check clearance interference and one
last one a rare one windmill I'll be
sharing about 20 examples of these
tactics in action if you're already
familiar with many of the terms I've
shared feel free to treat this as a
tactics exercise but for the most part
with each new puzzle that pops up I will
be really quick to simply show what the
solution is but if you're quick enough
feel free to pause the video and try and
figure it out on your own in each case
it will be white to move okay let's move
forward here let's get right to it
tactics what are tactics in chess
tactics in chess is a certain type of
play characterized by short-term attacks
and threats and the first tactic we're
going to have a look at is a fork a fork
in chess is when you move a piece or
pawn and it attacks two or more enemy
pieces or pawns so in this case here the
fork tactic is Knight to c7 was he doing
tacking two or more pieces king is in
check when he moves out of the way we
get the rook some might describe this as
a knight fork because it's the knight
who is attacking two or more pieces in
many of the puzzles that I show in fact
the great majority of the puzzles I show
here the the tactics will result in the
win of material the gain of material but
do know that we are not limited to just
that when it comes time for tactics it
can be something much more subtle like
the gain of gaining control of an
important square on the board a critical
square on the board okay let's have a
look at another fork tactic Queen seize
in this case forking both rooks if this
rook moves you get this one here and
it's similarly if he gets out of the way
we get the one in the corner one last
example of a fork this position on to e5
attacking these two minor pieces and
this bishop moves you get the knight if
the knight moves you get the bishop so
very often this can result in the wind
of material can be quite difficult to
deal with a fork having to meet two
threats in just one move let's move
forward here looking next at what a pin
is in chess a pin in chess we could
define as follows a pin is when you
restrict the movement of a piece such
that trying to move it may be either
illegal or unwise in this case here
Bishop c4 pins the rook to the king this
rook cannot move legally because the
King would be in check so this is an
example of a pin most commentators
myself included describe this as just a
pin and it's just a general we call it a
pin if you wanted to be a little bit
more specific about it you can describe
pins as either absolute or relative we
might want to identify this as an
absolute pin because a piece is pinned
to the King there's you know it could it
cannot move in this case because it
would be illegal we'll have a look at a
relative pin soon enough but first have
a look let's see at another absolute pin
pinning the Queen to the king in this
case the Queen can move but she is
certainly very limited she cannot move
out for this eighth rank because the
King would be in check on Queen takes
rook there's Bishop takes Queen so
that's another example of a pin in that
case another example of an absolute pin
and one last one let's have a look at
what's meant by a relative pin this is
quite common you'll see this in the
early stage of a game a bishop coming
out pinning the pinning the knight to
the Queen in this case
the night he can move but this is an
instance where would be unwise to move
the night as moving the night well
you're going to be dropping a serious
amount of material losing your queen
there so if black is not careful let's
say castles here this allows a move like
pawn to e5 and this is the big issue
just giving you a quick tip here when it
comes time for a pin if one of your
pieces in it isn't a pin like this your
quick tip is to simply get out of it as
soon as possible because this is the
risk you run which is to say having your
pinned piece being attacked and it's
unfortunate but he's attacked and he's
attacked by a pond normally he would
like to move but there's a serious
negative consequence of doing that in
this case so try and resolve pins as
soon as possible a better move would
have been something like d6 guarding
that square okay let's have a look next
out a skewer in chess what is a skewer a
skewer is when you attack a valuable
piece compel it to move to avoid capture
which then exposes a less valuable piece
for capture
okay that was a mouthful let's see what
it looks like in action Bishop to c4
attacking a valuable piece and well it
doesn't get any more valuable than the
King in the game when he moves out of
the way what do we get a piece of lesser
value we get the rook in this case this
is very similar if we're to go back with
our example of a pin this was the
example of a pin right all that has
changed when we look at skewer is the
order we have now the King here and then
the rook
it's they're very closely related
they're very similar pins and skewers
and it has to do in many cases with the
the order of the pieces on a particular
file diagonal or rank again when the
King moves out of the way we're getting
the rook attacking a piece that's
valuable and when it moves out of the
way
you're compelling it to move in this
case the King was in check you get the
piece right behind it
of lesser value okay it doesn't have to
always be directed towards a king as as
we will see in this example rook to b3
attacking the Queen valuable piece of
course she wants to get out of the way
and when she does what's happening well
we're able to get that piece that was
right behind her in this case the rook
on b8 and let's have a look at one last
example here interesting way to finish
this one up promoting painting a new
queen skewering the king in the Queen
the king is in checking when he moves
out of the way we get the Queen skewers
these will occur when multiple pieces
are on the same file rank or dog and
also you might want to be a little bit
cautious about of course how you
position your pieces in the game you are
maybe a little bit tactically vulnerable
if you have pieces lined up like this if
you have your king and your queen on the
same file rank or diagonal or your king
and rook etc so just throwing in some
quick tips along the way here let's move
on to what a deflection is in chess a
deflection is when you chase away a
piece from an important square now I
know that's a pretty general definition
but we'll see it in action we'll we'll
see how that what it looks like here
I'll describe it a little more
thoroughly the map but the deflection in
this case is Bishop takes pawn
deflecting the King away from this
important squared g8 well why is g8 so
important well from that square he has
an important role an important defensive
duty of watching over the rook because
White is having pressure on this square
here he's ready to take the rook so the
King is deflected away from the rooks
defense and white wins material like so
deflection typically occurs two pieces
that have defensive responsibilities so
in this case he clearly has a defensive
duty of watching over the rook you might
be tactically vulnerable you might be
vulnerable to the tactic of deflection
if you have cases like this in the in
your own game where your opponent could
take one of your pieces you're in a
position
in there to recapture because you know
the king is there as the defensive piece
but is he may be vulnerable to this
tactic of deflection can he be chased
away from that defensive duty in this
case he can let's have a look at another
example of a deflection there we go in
this case here we see that we would
really like to take the rook the king is
there as the defensive piece well
he's vulnerable in this case to the
tactic of deflection he's being now
chased away from the defense of the rook
and we could win that piece like so one
last example this one is just a little
bit involved and by that I mean two
moves deep of a tactic we have pressure
on this night this night here on f6 is
the defending piece we're going to look
to deflect him away from the Knights
defense we can do that with g5 tonight
doesn't have to move just yet the pawn
could take but after we recapture now
it's an unfortunate position this
defensive piece yet again is being
chased away from the defense of this
Knight here that has pressure on him so
if the knight moves out of the way we're
getting this guy and well if he doesn't
move he's just going to be captured by
the pawn so let's move on here let's
have a look at a discovered check what's
a discovered check in chess discovered
check is when you move a piece or a pond
so that another one of your pieces can
attack so in this case here this rook
here wherever he moves they will turn
out to being a discovered check so this
rook moves out of the way and it's this
new piece another piece that is
delivering some attack a check in this
case no matter where this rook goes he
won't be able to attack anything it'll
just be the bishop that's attacking the
King but more often than not these
discovered attacks are really turning
into double attacks as we will see
having a look at another discovered
check or I should say a double attack in
this case and notice this rook here and
Bishop as soon as the bishop moves now
two things are happening the
Brook is being attacked and the knight
is being attacked this is an instance of
now that discovered Czech but rather
discovered attack or what one might call
a double attack two pieces are being hit
the bishop is hitting the rook and the
rook is hitting the knight the rook
moves we get the knight and if the
knight was to move out of the way here
we're getting the rook so these are
quite difficult to deal with in fact if
you see your opponent have this type of
position on board and more experienced
player will recognize that this rook
here behind the bishop has a certain
potential energy all it takes is for
this bishop to move and this Knight is
really in the line of fire so it's
really a good idea to already see this
rook as having a direct influence along
this D file and get this knight out of
the way as soon as possible
let's have a look at one last example
here of a discovered check well in this
case it's not just a discovered check
but rather a double check and in this
particular case it turns out to be a
checkmate winning move here in this
particular case is Knight f5 double
check in chess is when two pieces attack
the King simultaneously and by its
nature a double check involves a
discovered check and in double check the
King must always move why is this the
case well the knight is attacking the
king the Queen is attacking the King if
it was just the knight attacking the
King you could take out the knight but
you have two issues there's two
different pieces you could only address
one of these two attackers and the King
is always having to move in this case
you might want to block the Queen check
but the knight is there you cannot cope
with both pieces attacking the king the
King must always try to move and in this
case he cannot this is the most forcing
we can say the most forcing move in
chess is this double check the King must
always move and he has no legal moves in
this case all these squares
are covered so let's have a look now at
just a few more terms here next one up
is clearance a clearance in chess is
when you move one of your pieces out of
the way of another and this will allow
one of your pieces to then make use of a
certain square file rank or diagonal so
in this case here it's a little bit more
complicated than the previous examples
what we would really like to have happen
is to get our Queen to this h7 square if
we can envision the Queen on this square
that would in fact be checkmate but the
bishop is in our way going here is just
to check the king would go to the corner
but we can clear we can clear this
diagonal in this case we can move this
Bishop out of the way do something
that's very dangerous attacking the
Queen and we now have a maintenance
retrofit akin that's game over and if
black does something about the main
threat like taking the knight well we're
getting the Queen so again these can
occur clearances occur so that we can be
making use of a a certain square file
diagonal or rank we just saw an instance
of clearing the way along a diagonal in
this position we can see an instance
where we're now clearing the way for
what exactly we're giving up our rook to
clear the way to make use of this h1
square can now give a check and then
finally we could get to the square here
and deliver checkmate two more examples
or I should say two more tactics this
one right here and the interference
tactic an interference is when you
disrupt the coordination between enemy
pieces it's usually a very good idea in
chess to stay coordinated to have your
pieces protected so in fact many many of
these tactics aren't working or won't
work in chess because if you are staying
coordinated it's very difficult to win
material but even in cases here where
you are well coordinated such as this
one here
the rooks are protecting one another
there's pressure on this rook however
you're still vulnerable to this
interference tactic in this case Knight
to c6 interfering with the coordination
between these two rooks and delivering a
check in this particular case if the
King is moving we're getting a full rook
so probably best for black is to take
this Knight out at least take someone
out instead of losing a full rook for
nothing
one last example of an interference
tactic in this case here we have the
coordination between the rook and the
Queen there's pressure on this rook here
how could we interfere with that
coordination well there is this move
Bishop to d5 attacking the rook and
cutting off the coordination interfering
with the coordination between the Queen
and the rook if the rook moves now we
can safely take this rook and well
however you slice it White's going to be
winning material in this case here as
well so one last tactic to have a look
at and then as a close we'll see just a
few examples of these common these
tactics in combination with one another
so this is a very rare tactic for sure
this windmill tactic a windmill tactic
is a combination where two pieces work
together to deliver an alternating
series of checks and discover'd checks
so in this case here we have rook takes
pawn this is a check and when the King
moves to the corner now we can move the
rook out of the way and this is now
discovered check the King must return
back and now we give another check force
the King in the corner and it's like we
always have a free move every other move
is like a free move with the rook we're
slowly gaining material one by one the
King has to keep going back and forth
again alternating these checks with
discovered checks and in each case white
is really killing team black at the end
of it what a big turnaround that would
be but again very rare tactic in chess
again a combination where two pieces
work too
to deliver an alternating series of
checks and discover'd checks now let's
have a look here as a close at just some
combinations some different ways you can
see these tactics tied in with one
another in this case with being with
white being on move here we have this
tactic of deflection notice that this
Knight is a defensive piece there's
pressure on e7
we're looking to deflect this Knight
away from its defense
unfortunately this Knight best well he
shouldn't move in this case because if
he does move there's now this follow-up
of a fork a knight fork or what we might
identify as a Royal fork since it is
attacking the king and queen so in this
case the knight should black should do
something other than move the knight
moving the knight is probably the worst
move but unfortunately we have this
tactic of a deflection and black is not
careful it could turn out to be also a
fork with the next move two more
examples this one here we have an
example of this first move being a fork
and depending on what black does next we
could hit black with another fork or
even a skewer for example if Queen takes
pawn in this case we play Knight here
hitting black with another fork this is
back-to-back fork example right here
upon coming up hitting two or more
pieces hitting these two pieces and if
the King takes well we can now hit black
with a skewer King is attacked and when
he moves out of the way there goes a
piece right behind the King one last
example coming up another example here
of position starting out or a tactic
tactical sequence tactical combination
starting out with a fork attacking the
knight in the pond it's not a wise
decision for white for black to take
here if he does well now this is setting
up the tactic of deflection notice the
tension on this d8 square the King is
the defensive piece in this case he is
vulnerable to the tactic of deflection
take spawn to flex the king away from
defense of the Queen and there goes the
Queen so we had a look at several
examples here again fork pin skewer
deflection discovered attack
double-check clearance interference
windmill very rare one hopefully this
was helpful to you we're improving our
vocabulary a little bit along the way
here and hopefully these tips that I
presented along the way will help you to
be a little bit more tactically aware in
your own games so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it and I will catch you in video
10 take care bye
you